all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts where
I give you my thoughts on life where
I give you my thoughts on the world
while I do my makeup drink coffee
whatever I'm doing that day
now today
guys you already know
you already know I am the queen of
Twitter I decided to recently call
myself the Picasso of Twitter
because I had this really great tweet
okay
I said fat chicks are fat I know I know
this is crazy to a lot of people but
it's like when we start to getting these
beluga whales on Twitter I just think we
need to reinstate fat chicks are fat
this is not hot this is very
unattractive
but I'm back into the arguing
you know I've officially decided
cheating is the hill I'll die on
everyone tells me to stop talking about
this everyone tells me that because I
really I don't advocate for cheating
right
but people just keep misquoting me and
misunderstanding what I'm saying
and therefore it irritates me so I have
to further argue
so today
um I found out in some interesting stats
okay
only 11 of men who cheat cheat multiple
times
and only three percent are serial
cheaters
now don't you think this could be
something that could be worked through
if the majority of the time
it's a one-time thing
call me crazy but again we go back to
this society that really feels like our
feelings are more important than the
family
because you know when you think about it
if you get cheated on and you never find
out
does it really affect your life
feminine women don't go looking for
problems feminine women aren't all up in
their Man's phone they're really living
their best life trying to be happy
and
the reason I always talk about cheating
is because it is such a double standard
it is such a double standard because
even Christian women
cream of the crop Christian women
will have open Instagrams
when
we all know Instagram is the number one
dating app in the world so why are you
on a dating app
with a husband now
call me crazy right I think this is a
bit of a double standard that we have in
society that we let women get away with
this stuff but if a man does it it's the
end of the world
now some people will say well Pearl
cheating and
seeking attention from men is not the
same thing okay well then you don't
believe in my premise then you know fine
but I think it's very similar because
attention women what was our mating
strategy get the best attention that we
could get from the highest value guy
and what was men's mating strategy screw
as many people as possible
so when we get married we're supposed to
compromise on our mating strategies I'll
stop looking for better and better and
better and
the men will stop screwing everything
they see that is a compromise but now
women want an open Instagram where they
post selfies and you know what the
Christians will come in and say well a
woman she can post selfies
is it really appropriate to be posting
your beauty if you have a beautiful wife
which I hope you would
um is it really appropriate to be
posting that when you're in a
relationship
now
call me I'm just asking the questions I
could be wrong I mean I could be very
wrong I don't know
um the next thing I wanted to say is I
had this thought
men really if we find a man that we want
to marry
men really are the prize
because no woman is going to marry a guy
that she doesn't feel like has some
things to offer so he's either good
looking
he's either got some resources
um or maybe funny Charming charismatic
like women it's funny because the the
Liberals will say oh you don't need that
much to get laid I know some bums that
make a girl laugh
and then bring her home
well you made her laugh that's what not
most guys aren't funny
um so that's a skill like that's social
status I think like historically and so
I was thinking about this I really do
think men are the prize because
most men didn't reproduce historically
so if you're reproducing with a guy that
means you deem him as Worthy
and if you deem him as worthy he is the
prize because he is going to be a whole
lot harder to replace
than you
unfortunately this is just the life of a
woman because at the end of the day even
if you're a 10 let's just say you're the
life of a woman that's okay
at 40 you're not going to be a 10
anymore you'll be like a six at best
unfortunately I don't say this with like
happiness in my heart
but
this whole idea that
women are the prize I just we're a
depreciating asset unfortunately men get
better with time women don't but you
know let me know what you guys think in
the comments like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel I guess I'm
dying on this cheating Hill I didn't
mean to but everyone's irritating me
because they can't hear what I'm saying
so you know
what are you gonna do like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
I'll talk to you next time